a rutgers professor was um interviewed
by
the race-baiting website the root and uh
she babbled on for several minutes
spewing blatant racism
but it's this part in particular coming
from a professor
that really caught my ear listen
i think that white people are committed
to being villains in the aggregate right
the real sort of issue here that you
know i've heard people sort of say it is
one i think that white people viscerally
fear it's not that white people don't
know right what they have done they know
they fear that there is no other way to
be human but the way in which they are
human which is to so you know like you
talk to white people and whenever you
really want to have a reckoning about it
they say stuff like you know it's just
human nature if y'all had all of this
power you would have done the same thing
right
and it's like no that's what white
humans did white human beings thought
there's a world here and we own it prior
to them black and brown people have been
sailing across oceans interacting with
each other for centuries without total
subjugation domination and colonialism
uh so we're going to kind of skip right
over the explicit racism
only because what else is there to say
about it other than this is explicit
racism
and um etc and so forth
reverse the races white professor saying
this about black people
uh they would be fired within 30 seconds
and there would be marches and rallies
and the president will be talking about
it and um so so so we know all of that
which isn't to minimize it but
we know all that
or at least the audience of this show
knows it
um but then coming from a professor
her her vision of history
where she says that uh black and brown
people they weren't they weren't
subjugating each other what
okay go go pick up any um history
textbook or
you know
this is something you could even this
one you could google
look up a list of um empires throughout
the world throughout history you're
going to see things like the ottoman
empire the aztec empire the mayan empire
the inca empire
the persian empire the egyptian empire
the assyrian empire et cetera et cetera
et cetera
these were not empires built and run
by white westerners or europeans
or white americans okay
but they're empires and and how do
professor
what do you think an empire is
how do you think an empire is
established
you know the ottoman empire when they
were building their their empire and it
was expanding
were they showing up to other countries
and other regions and um kind of
knocking on people's door very politely
and say would you mind
would you mind if we conquered you
yeah we got this empire thing going and
we really want to grow it and so we
would love to conquer
um you were you've got some land here we
would love to take it
would you mind
they said sure yeah go ahead take it oh
great and they shake hands well that's
not how it worked um these if it's an
empire at any point in history
especially ancient history
they were grown by conquering and
subjugating and killing and enslaving
all throughout the world
now
it's it's this is historical
misinformation and historical illiteracy
on multiple levels because she also says
that not only were they peaceful and not
subjugating each other which is a total
fantasy but that they were crossing
oceans
and interacting peacefully with uh the
people on the other side of the ocean
that's also not correct
now there were plenty of non-white
cultures who uh were
you know seafaring
like the you know especially the
polynesians for example
but
nobody was traveling whole oceans and
setting up lasting settlements
until western
uh
you know until europeans were doing it
they were the first to do it
to cross entire unknown oceans
go to an unknown part of the world and
set up a settlement
so she's also not correct about that
and and by the way
the non-white non-western empires that
were not
traveling across oceans
the reason why they didn't travel across
the ocean it's not because they had some
sort of ethical qualm with it it's not
because they said oh yeah there could be
um
there there could be usable land on the
other side of this this this huge body
of water and there there could be
resources and there could be slaves that
we could take but we're not going to do
that because you know we want to respect
their autonomy and um we want to and
they're going to be indigenous peoples
and
on that land mass and we want to respect
them
no they didn't do it because they lacked
the knowledge or the interest or the
ability
perhaps they didn't see it as in their
interest to you know there was enough
that they could take and steal and
conquer around them they need to travel
across the ocean to do it
college professor folks college
professor
and some of you in the audience are
paying
six figures i mean you are paying top
dollar you're paying enormous sums
to send your kids to school to listen to
[ __ ] like that
think about that for a second
i didn't go to college at all
i dropped at a community college after
one semester that's that's what i did
and i should i could be teaching her a
history lesson
i am far more knowledgeable than she is
as a as a i don't know what what subject
she teaches but as a college professor i
am far more knowledgeable than her
give me that money you know what if
you're gonna spend a hundred thousand
dollars sending your kid give me a
hundred thousand dollars and i will
teach your kid
i'm not gonna say i'm gonna do it it's
not that i'll do a tremendous job but
i'll do a better job than um than these
college professors will
you know what i'll do i'll cut i'll cut
it in half don't i'll do it for 50 000.
give me 50 grand and i'll and i'll
condense it i'll teach them in a month
they'll be in and out how about that
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated